now you remember I told you we have the
quadratic formula and it's cool put a
lot of work into it and now we can use
it for any quadratic right and then we
can see other interesting things like
this right when you get a new tool like
I I recently bought a arm I recently
bought a new screwdriver and it's like
10 times better than all my previous
ones and it's got this automatic and
then how to describe it anyway I'm not
very handy so Wow this thing is amazing
in my friend who's actually here he's
like dude I have one of those for 10
years anyway once you get a new tool one
of the first things you do is like wow
what cool stuff can I do with this like
I didn't think I needed stuff that
needed tightening around the house but I
go looking for things that I can tighten
just because I have it in tool right now
we have this new tool and so you might
want to think ok well now that I have
this let's expect all this effort like
developing it what else can I use it on
and here's an example right now this
equation here is a lot of quadratic it's
not a quadratic how do I know it's not a
quadratic yeah that's right like there
is an x-squared but there's something
else hanging around in here right this
is X to the power of 4 okay now if
you're curious this thing does have a
name because it's a 4 it's called a
quartic as in quad you know for for the
power is 4 it's not a quadratic however
I can deal with it using this tool as if
it were quadratic what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna play
some tricks to reduce this according to
a quadratic bring it down to the level
that I know how to deal with and then
I'm gonna solve this sucker okay so
here's what I'm going to do he's a
really important trick that method is
you play all the time and you will meet
again and again in your
12 which is going to be introducing a
substitution right it's sort of like a
bait and switch so this is all in terms
of X's but I'm going to introduce a new
pronumeral and traditionally it's the
letter U you can choose anything you
like but at least if which is a letter
you will be using the same one right now
what I'm going to do is I want to swap
out those those X to the four they're a
bit of a problem for me right so I want
to rewrite this equation so it doesn't
have X to the foreigners so it's not a
quartic anymore I want to rewrite it in
such a way that it looks like a
quadratic okay so what I'm gonna do is
what I'm going to swap these terms for
is instead of every time I see x squared
I'm going to write you okay so if u
equals x squared I didn't get rid of
this right that's nice how do I get rid
of this well if I Square this right if u
is x squared then u square will be x
squared square right x squared
sweat and by my index laws I know that's
X to the power of four okay so now I've
got something to get rid of the x
squared and I've got something to get
rid of the X to the power of four that's
gonna turn this into a quadratic watch
right
he's my substitution I'll say that's
just U squared right that's just my
straights well in here I've got eleven
you that's what I define from the
beginning plus 18
okay so I have rephrase my question
right I've taken this quarter question
I've reduced it down to a quadratic okay
what about here it's a quadratic in fact
it's not even a quarter it's a simple
quadratic
it's monic it can be factorized very
easily can you give me the pair of
numbers we're looking for what pair of
numbers 9 and to give me a little better
than that
negative 2 negative so I'm gonna chuck
in my to my yeah you happy with that
okay so now what I do this I can say
well
just like before that's two or nine
right but at this point I've gone as far
as I can go for solving you right except
the original question had nothing to do
with you you was like kind of a hack
that I introduced to make it solvable
okay so now that I've gotten to here I
want to get rid of the hack right go
back to what the question was originally
that which was exes right and right at
the beginning I said that u equals x
squared right
so down here I'm gonna go back to x
squared right so I've got two or nine
here right and now if you just look at
this one step at a time
so what is all you saw was that x
squared equals two right just like in
your quadratics okay over here you know
there's going to be two solutions to
that right position so what are the two
solutions just to that part of the
equation plus or minus the square root
of two right you square either of those
which is what this is supposed to do
you'll get two right but then you've got
this other hanging out over here right
so if this is all you saw x squared
equals mine then you would also be able
to say there's a plus or minus and it's
plus or minus three because 9 is a
perfect square
okay so I'm finished cool now this is
interesting by the way for quadratics
we're used to getting two solutions but
I have Cameron
one two three four solutions it's kind
of weird but it shouldn't be that
surprising because remember we said this
thing is a quartic right in fact if this
was a five you get five solutions if it
was a six you get solutions and on and
on okay so you'll get more right so this
method here what did we do just take a
step back when you see a chord equation
that's not a quadratic right see if you
can rephrase it as a quadratic and
reduce it down to a quadratic choosing
some kind of substitution right and this
is a very very common one which is why I
picked as my first example and then once
you've chosen that you just solve it
like a normal one okay in here okay
these are all of the steps in here where
I've used my my u substitution okay but
once I've gotten to the end of the line
with you I then get rid of it and I go
back to excess because that's what the
original question was about okay